it's fun tommy to get sunny gray back on
the hill you can already see the game
face as he came through the dugout
uh this is how sonny gray takes his
starts every fifth day he is ready to go
and i think we're all excited to watch
him back on the mound
hot shot to first backhand pick hero
wedding bottle underhand shovel
gray on the cover one down 0-2
strike three cold baez goes down looking
gray
with an exclamation point on a perfect
first inning
no score after half an inning alec mills
takes the mound and
he's put some very good ball games
against cincinnati for one thing he's
never lost to them a team against whom
he has
three and oh lifetime weak contact
ground balls and pop-ups
turbo swung on and missed right three so
two sinkers in on the hands a curveball
away
that's a pattern we've seen a few
thousand times in big league history
and it's a perfect perfect pitch
sequence in execution
he hits a fly ball into shallow left
center by us going out makes an
over-the-shoulder catch
let me correct that that was patrick
wisdom who caught that ball
he was the only infielder on the left
side of the diamond
here's the pitch to castiano swinging a
miss what is that like
compared to the rest of the league with
so many guys struggling that is an
amazing number to me
he hit better against lefty so i think
that might be the case
and it also tonight is probably a lot of
sunny gray back to back case he looks
pretty good
david ross in his second season
that's on the edge strike three
[Applause]
swing and a miss lost briefly by
barnhart he gathers put out
complete gray strikes out the side he's
tossing a one-hitter
with four wins
on the o2 got him
that's a bad pitch good result right
there the quarterback at that score
got him swinging swing like a movie star
an everyday player go out and do it but
it's
i don't think it's a part of the game a
very valued part of the game
strike three five k's for sonny gray
and peterson's got to be careful here
jim wolf our home plate umpire
giving him a lob of leeway well when the
catcher doesn't move his glove at all
he brought it up a little bit but i mean
he didn't try to
he didn't need to bring it six inches
inside that pitches the strike all day
long
first and second for javier baez
[Applause]
farmer goes to india force play to end
the inning
in his eighth season with the reds
got him two seamer across the top of the
strike zone for strikeout number
five for alec mills fourth inning is
underway anthony rizzo is struck out
sonny gray wins this one fastball strike
three
he's got six strikeouts four looking
long a b here by wisdom he's worked it
full second full count of the inning for
gray
foul tip strike three sonny gray showing
a well-located fastball at 91-92 still
gets the job done
and hayward has not had much success
against gray at all so
maybe get someone moving it lines one
toward right center in the gap bank said
it goes all the way to the wall bryant's
going to try to score
racing around third here comes the relay
india throws toward the plate bryant on
the way
scores with a slide at the plate hubs
lead one to nothing
jason hayward comes through with an rbi
double
one two to left field winker staggered
extends
leaps forward and jesse winker makes the
catch
not the cleanest green but what an
adjustment and he makes the play
ball right at just difficult to judge
for so long it was
joey violet just pure hitter
he hesitated and struck him out a called
strike three
and he'll have his say with jim wolfe
yeah
most of it was in the other direction
six strikeouts now for alec mills
generous no not generous
now next door they might be calling it
that
little tapper gray gathers
two down posey who had the year off last
year opted out i should say
driven toward right center drops in
and sliding into second safely ball gets
away from farmer
that two out ringing double from wilson
contreras
two outs two strikes contreras dances
and gray
pin points outside edge
fastball strike three eight k's for gray
[Applause]
got him not delayed a delayed strike
three call by jim wolfe
seven strikeouts for alec mills you
touched on it approaching
a career best struck him out gets away
but contreras will flip to first
mills so far so good here in the fifth
sonny gray is done five innings one run
struck out eight art warren
enters grounded a farmer nice backhand
from his knee to india one on the first
not in time great play by farmer on a
burner that seemed destined for left
so impressed by farm right here the
extension once again keep your hands
away from your body
get up and make the play and almost
turned it that is a great play
by kyle farmer my goodness he makes the
play
david bell makes a pitching change when
do you get the opportunity to face
a lefty
[Applause]
take the baton from sonny gray and they
post a
scoreless inning at the end of the
twilight hour here in cincinnati the
reds
batting against alec mills akiyama takes
strike three called
he didn't like the call that is
strikeout number nine
for alec mills right at the top of the
zone some guy named bonds at 0-4 for the
giants
up the middle into center field
india turns and holds fire in from brian
and a two-out hit from castellanos and
that's gonna do it for alec mills
five and two thirds one walk nine
strikeouts motto hit by pitch has struck
out looking
he cranks it to right field that's down
base hit
india around third he scores hayward and
right castiano's green light
he jumps home relay to the plate
coasting slides in safely
it pinballs off contreras and final
connects
pummels a two-run double and the reds
ahead two to one
reds up a run ninth benning the ball in
the hands
of the veteran heath hembree swing into
this he struck him out
the reds win it